the spirit of Christmas is quite
literally set up shop in the city
streets soon presents will start to
appear underneath Christmas trees all
over Europe but more and more gifts are
being bought online a trend that the
European Parliament has turned his
attention to the Parliament all-star
better protect consumers who shop online
whether they're buying music films apps
games or software if the product doesn't
match its description or isn't what it
should be
shoppers would be able to cancel a
contract or ask for a refund by
Christmas 2018 consumers will also have
access to a bigger range of products
thanks to the end of geo blocking
consumers won't be blocked anymore or
treated any differently from the locals
for things like hotel reservations car
rentals or purchases on websites from
other countries another goal is to
improve the quality and cost of
deliveries between EU countries but the
European Parliament also wants you to be
entertained more and more young
Europeans watch television and listen to
the radio online a new law will enable
European citizens to access the online
TV or film subscription content anywhere
in the EU from March 2018 subscriptions
to streaming platforms will no longer be
blocked once across the border this is
also why roaming fees have been
abolished now you can text make calls
and use the internet in another EU
country for the same price as you would
at home a new step towards helping
European citizens feel at home wherever
they are in the European Union